[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
five first responders now charged in the
death of elijah mclean a colorado grand
jury returning a 32-count indictment two
years after the 23 year old was killed
our goal seek justice for elijah
and r kelly's sixth accuser takes the
stand another woman tells a jury she too
was infected with herpes by the r b
singer plus both sides rest in the
robber durst murder trial the back and
forth questioning of the real estate
heir accused of killing his best friend
nothing further
long crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin we begin with a major
announcement out of colorado in the
investigation into the death of elijah
mclean a grand jury has returned a 32
count indictment against two police
officers one former police officer and
two fire department paramedics
elijah mclean died two years ago after
being placed in a chokehold by officers
then sedated by paramedics he was just
23 years old police body cam video
captured paramedics administering 500
milligrams of ketamine mclean yelled he
was an introvert that he was different
and begged for help
earlier this year an independent
investigation found there wasn't much
that was done properly when elijah
mcclain was stopped and it also found
the police investigation into the use of
force was flawed now a grand jury is
finding the actions of those first
responders criminal
late last thursday after a careful and
thoughtful deliberation the grand jury
returned to 32 top indictments against
aurora police officers
randy rodima and nathan woodward
former aurora police officer
jason rosenblatt
and aurora fire
rescue paramedics jeremy cooper and
peter
jacunian
for their alleged conduct on the night
of august 24
2019
that resulted in the death of
each of the defendants face one count of
manslaughter and criminal negligent
homicide they also face a slew of
different charges including
second-degree assault and crimes of
violence colorado's attorney general
says the paramedics will face specific
charges for administering ketamine
without consent
paramedics cooper
and shakunian
also face
one count second degree of salt with
intent to cause bodily injury and cause
bodily injury
one count second-degree assault for
recklessly causing serious bodily injury
by means of a deadly weapon
one count second-degree assault for a
purpose
other than lawful medical or therapeutic
treatment
intentionally causing super
unconsciousness or other physical or
mental impairment or injury
to mr mclean by administering a drug
academy without consent
i spoke to mclean family attorney after
they filed a wrongful death lawsuit
wanting to know why those first
responders administered ketamine
he did not have supernatural strength as
you can see from the video he is
completely restrained under a pile of
law enforcement officers by the
testimony of the officers about 700
pounds worth of cops were on top of this
140 pound man who was begging for his
life and saying that he couldn't breathe
so he certainly didn't exhibit that he
was uh responding appropriately he was
identifying himself he was saying his
name that he was trying to go home that
he hadn't done anything wrong that he
didn't have a weapon and they still
administered this drug which was
medically totally inappropriate and that
was a constitutional violation of his
right to bodily integrity we cannot
legally be given medication against our
will and that's what happened here
joining us today is the co-founder and
executive director of partners for
justice emily galvin almanza and terry
austin emily for two years i think we
all but gave up hope there would be
charges here what does the indictment
tell you about how the attorney general
is processing this case and do they give
you hope for justice
i think if anything what this
this case displays is
the failings of the local law
enforcement mechanisms here and i don't
just mean the police who did literally
everything wrong
in their contact with elijah mclean
whose case
remains
just staggeringly painful to think about
however the reason the attorney general
had to take this out of the da's hands
is because
at the outset the d.a and the cops did a
really bad job investigating themselves
and what happened when they did a really
bad job investigating themselves and
they got a forensic report that we don't
know biologically died couldn't have had
anything to do with the 700 pounds of
cops on top of him or the massive dose
of ketamine he was given
that investigation was fundamentally
unfair
so the fact that the state
took that away from local enforcement
and convened its own grand jury and the
people of the state of colorado said
this is
terry it's not just the charges there
also seems to be a civil rights pattern
and practice investigation which i think
emily is somewhat hinting at into the
aurora pd and the fire department what
does that mean
well the difference with this is a
pattern and practice investigation is
going to look at what the entire police
department or fire department is doing
here and in this case it's not going to
just focus on an individual person but
it's going to focus on what all of the
officers are doing and so it's to
protect individuals and to protect their
constitutional rights and in fact if it
is determined that the constitutional
rights of individuals like elijah
mcclain violated then you could see
changes in policies and practices and
basically changes in the way the police
and the fire department actually arrest
individuals and actually help
individuals absolutely let's say they're
looking at this at a very granular level
but also at a bigger picture and of
course we'll give you those updates in
the larger mclean case as they continue
turning now to more top legal news a
wisconsin man accused of killing and
dismembering his parents returns to
court law and crimes angina libya is
here with what happened
brian we've been following chandler
halderson's case and he has entered a
not guilty plea to the murders of his
mother and father now you may recall
bart and christa holderson disappeared
over the july 4th weekend their son
chandler reported them missing on july 7
near madison wisconsin but sheriff's
officials there say his story was
suspicious he then asked for a lawyer
and didn't talk with the investigators
anymore now the sheriff of dane county
told me there's a photo of chandler
halderson in the area where part of bart
holderson's remains were located and
remains identified as his mother krista
were also found
alderson remains in jail in madison
wisconsin he'll be back in court in
october and then his trial is scheduled
to begin in january of 2022
brian
thanks anjanet still ahead on law and
crime daily britney spears lawyers calls
for her father to immediately step down
from her conservatorship but first
another woman says r kelly exposed her
to herpes the shocking testimony at the
r b singer's sex trafficking trial our
legal analysis next
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
youtubetv today and then locate lawn
crime in the channel guide and for only
1.99 a month you can add the network to
your bundle watch lawn crime every day
with youtube tv we put you in the jury
box
[Music]
welcome back testimony r kelly
racketeering trial is continuing with
the six accuser faith testifying against
the disgraced king of rmb
faith who testified only with her first
name told the jury about how she
contracted herpes from kelly she
recalled their first sexual encounter
where she asked if he was going to use a
condom and he said quote we don't need a
condom faith was the first accuser to
testify she was not a minor when her
11th month sexual relationship with r
kelly began she was 19 when she met him
at his concert in texas in 2017. faith
described cold symptoms in 2018 shortly
after her relationship with kelly ended
followed by bumps all over her mouth she
was shocked when she went to the doctor
and was diagnosed with type 1 herpes
fate tried to get a hold of kelly but he
did not return her calls or texts after
getting a lawyer in texas kelly messaged
her and when asked why he did not tell
her that he had herpes kelly allegedly
said quote i don't know what you're
talking about but if i didn't know what
you were talking about we're not going
to have this conversation over the phone
faith also told the jury about a time r
kelly kept a gun by the bed while
forcing her to give oral sex faith was
the second accuser to testify about
contracting herpes from kelly and
kelly's longtime doctor chris mcgrath
had already testified that kelly was
being treated for herpes since 2007.
kelly has been mostly unresponsive to
the testimony in the trial so far his
face hidden behind a mask but for the
first time he shaked his head rubbed his
forehead and seemed unsettled as faith
testified about a sexual encounter where
she clenched up to avoid having sex with
him back to break down the latest in the
r kelly trial is co-founder and
executive director of partners for
justice emily galvanomanza and co-host
terry austin terry faith met kelly in
the same circumstances as some of the
other accusers is the enterprise and the
ricoh charge being made out or will that
come later
i definitely think that the enterprise
is being made out here it supports the
claim of the ricoh charge so for the
enterprise to be working here it's
supporting his music his brand and his
sexual activity and faith testified that
kelly paid for her flights he paid for
her hotel rooms and then he forced her
to have sex he demanded sex for her so
even though she's 19 and she was an
adult at the time her testimony is
definitely supporting the fact that he
had this enterprise and she was swept up
as part of that enterprise
now emily what does this level of
corroboration from the witness about
meeting kelly his treatment of them and
contracting herpes mean for the defense
is this case all but done for them
well there's a lot of problems the
defense has to overcome in this case but
i think it's actually interesting the
degree to which the media right now has
focused on a sexually transmissible
illness um there's a lot of hesitation
when it comes to things like this
because so often things that may be
gratifying when applied against a really
notorious alleged bad actor will then in
the future be applied dramatically
unfairly against people who are
disempowered
so for example in my practice as a
public defender i would often see people
who were you know hiv positive being
targeted by police for things that would
not be a crime for anybody else you know
you know his spittle flew in my
direction people using illness or a
diagnosis to stigmatize and create new
crimes for certain people i worry a lot
about that here and i don't think the
defense is worried about the
implications of what this herpes issue
or the attention it's being given does
in the case or for criminal legal policy
more broadly but i do have concerns
about how this case could be
extrapolated to less powerful people
absolutely there's a constant concern i
think that comes from a lot of these
major cases where you're talking about r
kelly harvey weinstein or bill cosby yes
you go after those individuals that you
truly believe are bad but the
implications that could apply to others
is definitely
a concept that i think many people
forget in these big major cases thank
you for bringing that up
now to more top legal news britney
spears's lawyer is calling for her
father's immediate resignation from her
conservatorship
the pop star's father has been the
conservator of her estate for over 13
years however in two separate court
hearings this summer britney spears
described the arrangement as abusive
after a long legal battle jamie spears
officially agreed to step down but on
his own time now attorneys for the toxic
singer are calling for his immediate
resignation without the two million
dollar payout he's requesting to cover
legal and management fees the next
hearing is scheduled for september 29th
now to more on the doomsday deal with
chad and lori daybel chad's children are
speaking out in a new interview with
cbs's 48 hours and are pointing the
finger at lori saying the reason the
bodies of her two children were found in
chad's backyard must be because he's
being framed
i don't know
but i do know that if he were to commit
a crime he wouldn't be foolish enough to
put the evidence in his own backyard he
knew how to dig graves
and that just doesn't sound believable
to me he was framed
it all goes back to this woman says emma
her father's new wife lori valo dabel
i think he was fooled in the worst most
deadly way possible
you can watch the entire interview on
cbs is paramount plus
coming up on law and crime daily a
neighbor's testimony that could point
the finger on another suspect in ohio v
stanley ford plus jury selection in the
trial of former theron ceo elizabeth
holmes the questions potential jurors
are being asked after the break
[Music]
welcome back jury selection and
elizabeth holmes federal trial is in its
second day the former theranos ceo was
back in court as dozens of potential
jurors face more rounds of questioning
potential jurors are being asked if
they've seen any of the documentaries or
podcasts about elizabeth holmes holmes
is facing a dozen fraud and conspiracy
to commit fraud charges related to her
now defunct blood testing startup
theranose nearly 200 perspective jurors
filled out a questionnaire before coming
to court about half indicated they
already consumed some media about the
case holmes is pleading not guilty and
opening statements are expected next
week she faces up to 20 years in prison
if convicted
switching gears to ohio where stanley
ford stands trial accused of setting
deadly fires in his akron neighborhood
three fires nine fatalities 29 charges
the accusation stanley forward is facing
in court ford's trial originally started
last year with the pandemic force a
mistrial the trial has now restarted and
if ford is convicted he could face the
death penalty neighbors and friends of
the victims have taken the stand
testifying about what they know about
stanley ford and other people who
frequent in the neighborhood prosecutors
call neighbor beverly ewing virtually
and both sides questioned her about a
stranger who took a particular interest
in the fire that occurred at victim
lindell lewis's home
so we know it wasn't stanley ford
correct
that's correct
that black man when he got out of that
vehicle had a big smile on his face did
he not
yes and he was very interested in what
had just occurred in the neighborhood
was he not
yes
and what did he say objection
overruled he wanted to know what had
happened in the area um
and he said it looks like a fire
and then he said
well he kind of laughed with a big smile
on his face and said you know how it is
black people kill their own black
people the fire investigator
coincidentally a friend of victim
lindell lewis then took the stand he
gave an overview of the conversation he
had with the defendant during the
investigation
stanley said that lindell was a vicious
guy
that
he
had people
hanging out on his porch with him
making fun of people come by verbally
attacking them when we come back durst's
intense cross-examination finally comes
to an end after nine days we'll redirect
strain out dursa's story find out next
[Music]
welcome back big news out of california
and the murder trial of robert durst
both sides have now rested saying they
presented all of their evidence
robert durst is on trial for the murder
of his best friend susan berman durst
was on the stand for nearly three weeks
over half of it under a grueling
cross-examination by prosecutor john
lewin lewin worked to establish that
durst cannot be a credible witness given
his track record to lie and come up with
stories on the stand this also includes
lies that he apparently told to andrew
durecki the director of the jinx
docu-series prosecutor lewin said he
planned to call jorecki in a rebuttal
case but decided against it lewin
wrapped up his questioning by
highlighting what he calls durst's
affinity for lying
mr durst it's my last question as you
sit here right now i'm gonna ask you did
you kill susan berman
no
but if you had you would lie about it
correct correct
nothing further thank you
in a comparatively quick redirect dick
der guerin questioned the real estate
air about his relationship with kathy
and susan
even though you had problems did you
still love kathy
yeah
have you ever loved anybody in your life
more than cathy no
did you kill her
oh
i was closer to susan
than anybody
with the exception of kathy
truly was a friend
i had other friends
but none of my other friendships were
like my friendship with students
did you kill susan no
do you know who did
no
then in recross loon brought up the
jailhouse phone call between durst and
his current wife where it sounds like
he's confessing to the murder of his
first wife kathy
and mr durst do you in any way respond
to your wife
well i didn't get rid of kathy i didn't
kill her
douglas couldn't have helped me because
i didn't have anything to do with it do
you say any of those things
in fact your response mr durst is to say
depending on how things go
you might confirm that's what happened
correct
mr durst please explain how that is
anything other than a confession
to you having disposed of your wife's
body
it is not a confession
of me having disposed of my wife's body
emily this may have been a long
examination of dirt for all of us but
according to law and crimes people in
the courtroom the jury have been
attentive and taking notes the entire
time does this spell disaster for durst
i never put too much stock in juror
notes not the notes they send back to
the court not the notes they take for
all you know someone was drawing a
cartoon during that three-week
examination i wouldn't blame them
because if you as a lawyer take up that
much of a jury's time without some
really
non-repetitive riveting material the
jury's gonna get distracted
i would say that there are certain
moments
in that examination and in the demeanor
of mr durst that absolutely would give
me great concern as his defense lawyer
but the jury taking notes i wouldn't
read too much into that all juries take
notes or amuse themselves with the only
tool they've got which is their notebook
and their pen gotcha so maybe it's a few
pictures in the margins maybe it's notes
we'll never know but can't read too much
into it i would fully agree with that
terry there was a lot of back and forth
about uh andrew jackie jarecki sorry the
producer of jinx testifying he's not why
is that
there was a lot of going back and forth
lewin wanted jerecchi to testify because
he wanted him to refute durst's claim
that directly told him to say what he
said and made him look like a bad guy
for the film
but at the end of the day you know they
stipulated that directly would testify
about certain issues and that was
because they were protecting the
journalistic rights and
ultimately the defense said no i want to
do more than that i want to cross
directly i want to show his bias i want
to show his motivation and it they went
back and forth a lot and
judge actually said look you've already
shown that durst is lying and at the end
of the day lewin agreed he'd already
done a good enough cross-examination on
durst he didn't need to call directly as
a rebuttal witness and so they just
decided no he's not coming in to testify
interesting has lewin learned that less
is more didn't think it was going to
happen but thank you both and thank you
for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
you